pour faire nous vous faisons chevaliers
de la Légion d'honneur
[Applaudissements]
sauf que je suis très émue
c'est un bon moment de la vie de Nice
bombardier en fait il y a plusieurs
d'entre nous qui ont été étonnés ce
matin d'apprendre le décès de la
journaliste et autrice c'était une
grande débatteuse qui osait exprimé ses
idées même si ça pouvait choquer
certaines personnes elle s'était éteinte
des suites d'un cancer à l'âge de 82 ans
et j'en parle avec Daniel lorrain vous
êtes autrice comédienne bonjour vous
êtes une grande amie aussi de donner de
bonbons
donc ce soir on lui rend hommage
ensemble en parlant de sa vie de sa
carrière et tout ça puis en fait moi ce
qui marque en écoutant les extraits
d'entrevue puis quand la côtoyé tout ça
c'est une femme qui
oser choquer c'est
oser choquer là c'est quelque chose
quand même à l'air des réseaux sociaux
puis la critique puis en plus d'une
femme qui a dû faire sa place d'être
capable de faire ça c'est quelque chose
forte je lui disais tout le temps mais
comment tu fais moi je suis incapable de
faire ça mais non mais tu sais mais ça
va mais
c'était
sa façon de faire il fallait secouer le
secouer les branches
faire tomber les les fruits puis après
on dégage les bonnes pommes des pommes
pourries et puis tu sais on y va et puis
on discute et puis on argument et puis
on a les arguments pour le pour le faire
et ça c'était toujours très important
elle était peut-être pas toujours
d'accord on n'était pas toujours
d'accord ensemble je suis pas d'accord
avec toi là c'était dur de débattre avec
elle parce qu'elle était préparée
tout le temps préparez-vous et puis elle
avait des arguments longs comme ça puis
là elle te travaillais au corps pour
arriver à te convaincre de d'adhérer à
son point de vue et puis finalement
c'est toujours un peu par un tu sais
mais dis non mais je comprends je
comprends ton point de vue ça va mais
elle revenait à l'achat et puis quand tu
texte est réglé deux jours après ok
mais c'est justement sa façon d'être à
faire en sorte qu'elle a tracé un chemin
est quand même elle avait son style à
elle puis elle a tracé un chemin
notamment pour les femmes moi j'ai
aujourd'hui que ça avait été la première
à produire et à animer une émission
d'affaires publiques télévisé donc ça
fait partie de son lait quand même ce
que ce qu'elle a fait pour les femmes
tout ce que le fait pour les femmes ce
qu'elle a fait le chemin que le tracé
dans le domaine de l'information qui
était
domaine monde quand même réservé plutôt
aux hommes et elle est vraiment comme on
dit l'expression faire éclater des
plafonds de verre elle a fait ça durant
durant toute sa carrière oui elle était
très fier de ça était
contente elle était une battante
ce qui comptait c'était de continuer de
faire de
[Musique]
il y avait toujours un moyen on y va
c'est là c'est une détermination
mais je pense il y avait un feu qui qui
alimentait et jusqu'à la fin on sentait
toujours toujours s'il y a quelques
jours encore à maudit mais tu sais c'est
pas c'est pas pour tout de suite là je
vais je vais je vais me reprendre je
vais
c'est pour ça on ne pouvait pas penser
que que c'était rendu à ce point-là rien
ne laisser présager ça il y a encore
quelques semaines en tout cas elle
laisse des très bons souvenirs pour
beaucoup de gens puis merci pour
l'hommage que vous lui avez rendu ce
soir le mérite bien puis encore une fois
je vous offre toutes mes sympathies
merci aussi à ses collègues